hi welcome to Mario's math tutoring my
name is Mario we're going to be working
through some problems today specifically
how to work with proportions and so
let's get right into it so first thing
is what is a proportion well what a
proportion is it's a ratio equal to a
ratio so a ratio is comparing two
quantities so it's like a fraction equal
to another fraction and because it's an
equation the left side the right side
are equal and there's a couple different
ways to approach these problems one way
to do it is whatever you do to the
denominator you want to do to the
numerator so for example if you were to
multiply the denominator by a certain
quantity you would want to multiply the
numerator by the same quantity so you
don't change the overall value of that
fraction same thing with if you divide
the denominator by a certain number you
want to divide the numerator by that
same number adding subtracting that
won't work so it's just multiplying and
dividing you want to make sure you do
the same thing to the top and the bottom
so here what we're going to do is we're
going to say hmm twelve times four
equals 48 so if I multiply the bottom of
this fraction by four I want to also
multiply the numerator by four so you
can see that X must be four and if you
reduce this 448 reduces down to 1 12 so
you can see that our answer for X is 4
okay let's look at another example this
one we have 15 / 24 equals 45 over X so
another way to do this problem is
instead of saying okay 15 times 3 is 45
if I multiply the top by 3 let me
multiply the bottom by three another way
to do this is to cross multiply they
call it the cross product so the product
of these two multiplied together equals
a product of these two multiplied
together okay so you're with me so far
these are kind of large numbers though
so what you might want to do is you
might want to reduce this fraction first
so 3 goes into 15 5 times 3 goes into 24
8 times i divided the top and the bottom
by the same number so it's the same
equivalent fraction right so now what
we're going to do is we're just going to
cross multiply so we have eight times 45
equals 5x so 5 times x equals 8 x 45 so
let's just see what 810
45 that's 4360 okay so 360 and then what
we're going to do is we're going to
solve for one x by dividing by 5
dividing by 5 and so now we get 72 and
that's it you got it now if you want to
check your answer you can put it back in
45 / 72 yes that's the same thing as 15
/ 20 4 or 5 / 8 you can divide it on
your calculator you'll see you'll get
the same decimal okay last example here
we're going to do that same cross
product technique that cross multiplying
but notice now what we have is we have
two terms a binomial in the denominator
so what we're going to want to do is
we're going to actually want to
distribute so we have three times the
quantity X plus 2 so I'm putting it in
parentheses k equals 4 times 9 which is
36 now i'm just going to distribute the
3 so that's 3x plus 6 equals 36 i'm
going to subtract six from both sides so
that's 3x equals 30 and if i divide both
sides by 3 you can see we're going to
get x equals 10 again if you want to
check your work go ahead and put it back
in 9/12 that's the same thing as 3/4 and
you can verify that you've got the right
answer so I hope you're enjoying these
videos go ahead and subscribe to the
channel and I look forward to seeing you
in a future video